ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้โรงเรียนสุรธรรมนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนกลับมาเจอกันนะ
ครับวันนี้วันนี้วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันที่
ตอนนี้วันที่
26 ค่ะอ้าหอมวันนี้วันที่ 26 ใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะประกาศวันนี้วันที่ 26 แล้ววันนี้
วันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันอาทิตย์วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมครับใช่
ค่ะนี้วันอาทิตย์แต่วันอาทิตย์ที่ 26
โอเคแล้ววันอาทิตย์ที่ 26 เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือน
ธันวาคม
5 เดือนธันวาคมใช่ไหมครับแต่ณเดือน
นะว่าเมียพี่เขาเปลี่ยนประกันใหม่ตึ๊ดๆ
นี่เดือน
ถ้าผมปีปีซอลต.ตะไรครับปีคศ
2000  21 ค่ะ
2021 ใช้ครับแล้วปีพตอะไรครับข้อ
2564 ค่ะโอเค 2,000
564 ครับ 5 แล้วก็วันนี้วันที่ 16 เมื่อ
วานเมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันอะไรครับเมื่อวาน
วันที่ 25 เป็นวันคริสต์มาสค่ะๆเมื่อวาน
วันที่
25 เป็นบอล Christmas ในครับโอเคใช่ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้
วันจันทร์ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์นะครับโอเค
เมื่อวานวันเสาร์ในครับหน้าแล้วอันนี้
ครับวันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันกี่โมง
ครับ
05:10 นอ่าตอนนี้ 5 โมง 10 นาที
05:10 น 5 เป็นตอนเย็นใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะ
ตอนเย็นเอาเคเดี๋ยวเราไปเรียนภาษาไทยกัน
นะครับหน้าเดี๋ยวเราไปดูการวันนี้เพื่อ
ตี้มีสัตว์นะครับมีสัตว์หลายๆอย่างให้มา
ให้นักเรียนถ้วยคิดคิดว่าสัตว์สัตว์ชอบ
ชอบกินอะไรนะครับหายแล้วเป็นห้องสัตว์ตัว
ที่ 1 สัตว์ตัวที่ 1 หน้านะครับตัวนี้
ครับนี่
ตัวอะไรครับน้องเรียมตัวนี้ตัวอะไรครับ
ลิง
ก็ลิงใช่ไหมตอนนี้ลิงกำลังคิดอยู่ผมกำลัง
คิด
ปลาไหมอยากกินปลาไหม
หน้านี้ปลาอันนี้เรียกปลานะครับอ่าเห็น
ปลามั้ยน้องเรียนเห็นปลานะครับหล่าอ้ายมี
ตา
มีปลากี่ตัวครับมีปลาหนึ่งตัว
ปลา 1 ตัวนะครับถ้าแล้วเจ๊มีปลาแล้วอัน
นี้อันนี้อะไรครับขนมปังค่ะขนมปังอ่ะน้อง
เรียมคิดว่าลิง
ชอบกินปลาไหมหรือหรือลิงชอบกินขนมปังครับ
เตรียมคิดว่า
ลิง
ไม่ชอบกินปลาอ๋ออ๋อลิงไม่ชอบกินปลาโทรหา
แล้วขนมปังล่ะครับชอบไหม
เตรียมคิดว่า
ลิงชอบกินขนมปังลิงกินขนมปังได้ใช่ไหม
ครับได้
เกือบเคยเห็นพี่อัดดีก็เคยเห็นอันต่อไป
ครับอันนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
กระดูกหมอกระดูกเพื่อนดูมีสีขาวมีเป็นรูป
กระดูกอ๋อลิงกินกระดูกไหมไม่กินค่ะ
เพลงไม่กินกระดูกใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะกิน
กระดูกไม่ได้อะลิงไม่กินกระดูกอ่ะแล้วก็
อันสุดท้ายอันนี้เปียตี้คิดว่าลิงน่าจะ
กินได้อันนี้อะไรครับกล้วย
555 กล้วยกล้วยสีเหลืองๆนี้เรียกกล้วยนะ
ครับหน้าลิงกินกล้วยไหมครับ
ตัวเองจริงไหมกินกล้วยค่ะอ๋ออ๋อกินกล้วย
โอเคอ๋อกล้วยนะครับกล้วยกับขนมปังลิงชอบ
อันไหนมาก
ที่สุดครับ
ลิงชอบกินกล้วยมากที่สุดอ๋อชอบกินกล้วย
มากที่สุดนะชอบมากที่สุดสัตว์ตัวต่อไปนะ
ครับน้า
อะไรนะตอนนี้ครับตัวนี้
ตัวอะไรครับเพนกวินใช่ไหมโหเพนกวินตัว
ใหญ่มีขั้วนมากเพนกวินมีปากมีปากแหลมปาก
แหลมนิปากแหลมวณิช 5 แหลมใช่ครับปากแหลม
อ้าโอเคแล้วก็อ่านดูซิดูว่ามีมีอะไรให้
เพนกวินกินบ้างหน้ามีอะไรบ้างครับนี้อัน
นี้อะไรครับสีเขียวนี้สีเขียวนี้อะไรครับ
ใบไม้
ใบไม้อ่ะเพนกวินเพนกวินกินใบไม้ไหมกินไหม
กินไหมครับไม่นะคะ Hat เว้น
ไม่กินใบไม้หอมไม่กินใบไม้อ่ะอ่าเพนกวิน
ไม่กินไปไม้อ่านแล้วสีแดงนี้ครับสีแดงนี้
อะไรครับอ่ะแอปเปิ้ลค่ะ
แอปเปิ้ลใช่ไหมครับอ่ะเพนกวินเพนกวินกิน
แอปเปิ้ลไหมครับเรียมคิดว่า
แพนกวินไม่กินแอปเปิ้ลไม่ชอบกินแอปเปิล
ให้ครับ
ไม่หักถ้างั้นต่อไปต่อใบเป็นนี้นี้พี่
ติ๊กคิดว่าคิดว่าเป็นกลิ่นน่าจะชอบอันนี้
นี้นี่อะไรครับ
ลาขอ
ปลานะครับอ่าเป็นปลาเพนกวินชอบกินปลาใช่
ไหมครับใช่ค่ะอ่าเพื่อติ๊กเคยเห็นเคยเห็น
เพนกวินกินปลาเป็นกลิ่นป้ายน้ำว่ายน้ำใน
ทะเลในทะเลแล้วก็เป็นวิ่งก็จับป่านี้
เนี่ยไป
จับปลาน้ำเค็มกวิ้น in ป่า
แล้วสีเหลืองนี้ครับสีเหลืองนี้เมื่อกี้
เรารู้จักแล้วใช่ไหมนักเรียนรู้จักแล้ว
ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะสีเหลืองนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
ร่วยอ้าใช่ครับสีเหลืองนี้คือด้วยห้าง
เพนกวินกินกล้วยไหมไม่นะคะเห็นกินชอบกิน
ปลามากที่สุดน่าใช่ครับน่าไม่กินกล้วยไม่
กินแอปเปิ้ลไม่กินใบไม้ใช่โอเคเดี๋ยวเรา
ไปดูสัตว์ตัวต่อไป
โอ้ยมา
นิมีแมวมีหนวดและอ้าเป็นแมวแต่แมวตัวนี้
เป็นไงครับอ้วนทรายแมวทีมเยอะหากินเยอะ
เหมือนเพนกวิน
ถ้าเป็นกวิ้นเกาะอ้วนอ่าเพนกวินซิมเยอะ
อ่ะแมวก็กินเยอะ
แล้วแมวกินอะไรครับ
แมวกินอะไรครับอันนี้อันนี้อะไรครับเนี่ย
ชีส
ทีชหน้าแมวกินชีสไหมกินไหมไม่
ไม่น่าแมวไม่ชอบกินชีสนะครับอ่ะแล้ว
กระดูกล่ะครับแมวชอบกินกระดูกนะ
ไม่ค่ะไม่ชอบไม่ชอบกินกระดูกแล้วกล้วยล่ะ
ครับชอบเก่งด้วยไหมไม่ชอบค่ะอ๋ออ๋อแล้ว
นี่อันนี้อันนี้อะไรครับเฮียที่เห็นอัน
นี้ใส่ถ้วยอยู่นมให้ไหมครับอ่านมแมวชอบ
กินนมไหมครับแมว
เดี๋ยว
พี่เตรียมคิดว่าชอบละห้าใช่ครับแมวชอบกิน
นมนะ
แมวชอบกินนมโอเคนะครับอ่ะต่อป้ายไปดู
สัตว์ตัวต่อไปนะครับ
นี้ตัวนี้ตัวอะไรครับ
สิงโต
สิงโตนะครับอ่ะมีอะไรให้สิงโตกินบ้างครับ
หน้ามีอันนี้อ่านี้เรารู้แล้วเมื่อกี้มัน
เรียกว่านมใช่ไหมนมค่ะต่อชอบกินนมไหมครับ
ชอบไหมเตรียมคิดว่าไม่ชอบ
ไม่ชอบใช่ไหมครับโอเคถึงโตไม่ชอบกินนม
อ่านแล้วตอบๆอันนี้อันนี้อะไรครับมี
เนื้อดีเนื้อ
5สิงห์โตชอบกินเนื้อไหมครับ
ชอบค่ะอ๋อ
ชายครับสิงโตชอบกลิ่นเนื้อนะครับน้าโอเค
โอเคแล้วสีเขียวนี้สีเขียวนี้อะไรครับ
คลิกหยวกอ่าพริกหยวกใช่ไหมครับโอเคสิงโต
ทอดกินพริกหยวกไหมชอบไหมครับไม่ชอบค่ะไม่
ชอบใช่ไหมชอบไม่กินพริกหยวกอ่ะ
สิงโตไม่ชอบหาแล้วอันนี้ล่ะครับอันนี้
อะไรครับน้ำครึ่ง
น้ำผึ้งแอร์
สิงโตชอบกินน้ำผึ้งไหมชอบไหมไม่
เสือสิงโตไม่ชอบกินน้ำผึ้งน้ำผึ้งสิงโต
ไม่ชอบพริกหยวกสิงโตมายชอบนมสิงโตก็ไม่
ชอบกดชอบกินมีเนื้อหัวใจค่ะ 5 ชอบกิน
เนื้อโอเคเราไปดูสัตว์ตัวต่อไปครับ
หน้าตัวนี้อะไรครับ
กระต่ายอ่ากระต่ายกระต่ายกำลังกำลังคิด
อยู่แกเราจะกินอะไรดีนะกระต่ายพูดเราจะ
กินอะไรดีแทคอินล่วยกินไหมกล้วยกินไหม
กระต่าย
กินไหมคะ
หน้าเพจที่คิดว่ากระต่ายก็ออกมาแต่กิน
กล้วยได้แต่อาจจะไม่ชอบไม่ชอบชอบอีกนิด
หน่อยกินนิดหน่อย
ใช่ค่ะ The คิดมากกินได้แต่ว่า
เรียงคิดว่าไม่ได้ชอบ
จ่ายไม่ชอบนะครับ 5 โอเคแล้วต่อไปต่อไปมี
ก็ดูอันนี้ก็ต่ายชอบกินกระดูกไหมครับไม่
ค่ะตัวตายชอบกินกระดูก
อันนี้นะครับอันนี้มันคือชีสนะแค่อันนี้
ก็ตายกระต่ายชอบกินชีสมั้ยไม่ค่ะไม่ชอบ
ใช่ไหมครับหาก็ตายไม่ชอบกินชิดเองแล้วอัน
นี้ครับอันนี้อะไรครับอันนี้สีส้มและมีสี
เขียวตรงนี้อะไรครับแครอท
แครอทอ๋อ
ชายแครอท 4 ส้มได้เนื้อหาแล้วกระต่ายชอบ
กินแครอทไหม
ชอบค่ะโอเคกระต่ายชอบกินแครอทอ่ะต่อไป
ครับหน้ามีสัตว์อีกตัวนึงตัวสุดท้ายตัว
นี้ตัวอะไรครับเตรียมคิดว่าแกะอ้าให้เออ
นี้เป็นแก่ใช่ครับอ่าแคะ a แล้วแก่กิน
อะไรครับกินชีสไหม
ไม่ค่ะให้กินน้ำไม่กินชีสแล้วแกะกินปลา
ไหม
ปลานี้ปลาไม่กินปลาค่ะไม่กินปลาแล้วตัว
นี้ตัวอะไรกับเนี้ย
ไส้เดือนอ๋อค่ะให้เดือนหรอแคะกินไส้เดือน
ไหมครับหินไหมก็ไม่ค่ะกินหรอเหลืออันนี้
แล้วอันนี้สีเขียวเขียวๆนี้อะไรครับย่า
ย่าย่า 5 แกะกินหญ้าไหมครับแกะกินหญ้าค่ะ
อ๋อแกะชอบชอบกินหญ้าอ่า
เฮียตี้มีเกมมีเกมให้ให้นักเรียนอาให้
น้องเรียมช่วยกันหาหาหา
อาหารอาหารที่สัตว์ชอบกลิ่นกาย 5 กล่อง
สี่เหลี่ยมสีอะไรบ้างครับมีสีแดง
สีแดงสีม่วงสีม่วง
สีฟ้าสีฟ้า
สีเหลืองสีเหลืองเขาแชร์อามีสีสีแดงสี
ม่วงสีฟ้าสีเหลืองก็แค่เดียวให้น้องเรียม
เปิดเปิดกล่องได้ครั้งละ 2 กล่องนะเพื่อ
เพื่อหาโอเค
ตรงไหนดีครับสีอะไรตรงไหนครับ
สีแดง
ข้างบน
ข้างบนครับข้างบนมีสีแดง 2 อันนี้หน้า
น้องเรียมเลือกอันไหนครับอ่ะโอเคเรียน
เลือกสีแดงทางขวาหรือทางซ้ายครับเตรียม
เลือกสีแดงทางขวา
5 ทางขวาคือสีแดงอันนี้เพื่อที่จะเปิดนะ
ครับอ่ะนี่ตัวอะไรครับแมวหรอคะแล้วไม่ใช่
ครับแมวชอบชอบกินอะไรครับ
แมวชอบกิน
หัว
นมดูดนม 5 ใส่ครับอ้าน้องเรียมคิดว่านม
อยู่ตรงไหนครับอยู่สีเหลือง
สีเหลืองหน้าสีเหลืองด้านบนหรือด้านล่าง
ครับ
ด้านบนด้านบนหน้าด้านบนอยู่ซ้ายหรืออยู่
ขวาครับอยู่ขวาอยู่ขวาโอเครูปนี้เดี๋ยว
พี่ติ๊บเปิดคิดว่าจะเป็นนมไหมครับนมไหม
สาดลองเปิดเลยอะโอ๊ย
ใช่นมไม่ใช่นมกล้วยเป็นกล้วยอ่ะตัวอะไร
ชอบกินกล้วยครับลิงลิงอ้าโอเคถ้างั้นอ้าว
เรามาหาลิงกันครับน้องเรียมคิดว่าลิงอยู่
อยู่ที่ไหนครับ
อยู่สีแดง
ตายอื่น
ซ้ายมืออันนี้ด้านบนหรือด้านล่างครับ
ด้านบนหรือด้านล่างอ่าด้านบนอันนี้ใช่ไหม
ครับไอสัสออกมาอ๋อ
ใช่ลิงมาให้ใช่ลิงๆเดี๋ยวพี่ให้น้องเรียม
เลือกใหม่เลือกใหม่อีก 2 ภาพหน้าสีม่วง
สีม่วงอ่าด้านบนหรือด้านล่างครับด้านล่าง
ด้านล่างโอเคด้านล่างมี 2 อันมีสีม่วง 2
อันเอาสีม่วงด้านขวาหรือด้านซ้ายครับเอา
สีม่วงด้านซ้ายด้านซ้ายโอเคอ้าพี่เปิดอ่า
โอเคอาทิตย์เจอสิงโตสิงโตทอชอบกินอะไร
ครับ
สิงโตชอบกินเนื้ออ๋อแล้วเนื้อนักเรียนคิด
คิปชั่นเนื้อให้อยู่ตรงไหนครับเปียตีจำ
ได้แท็กเรียนจำได้ไหมคะให้ไหมเนี่ยอยู่
ตรงไหนครับเนื้ออยู่สีแดงเนื้ออยู่สีแดง
สีแดงด้านบนหรือด้านล่างครับด้านบนนั่นบน
โอเคตรงไหนครับด้านขวาหรือด้านซ้ายด้าน
ซ้ายด้านซ้ายตรงนี้อ้าถูกต้องครับมีเนื้อ
มีสิงโตสิงโตชอบชอบกินเนื้อต่อไปครับให้
โรงเรียนเปิดอีก 2 ใบสีฟ้า
สีฟ้าอ่าสีฟ้าจะมีด้านบนแล้วก็สีฟ้าด้าน
ล่างเอาเปิดร้าครับได้จ้างดารา
อันล่างหน้ามีนั่นขวาแล้วก็ด้านซ้ายเอา
กล้องไหนดีครับสีฟ้าด้านซ้ายปลาด้านซ้าย 5
นี้อ่าเพื่อตี้เปิดสีฟ้าด้านซ้ายนะครับ
ปึ๊บโอ้โหเป็นอะไรครับแซ่บตายๆอ่ากระต่าย
ชอบกินอะไรครับชอบกิน
แครอทแครอทหน้าแครอทน้องเรียมคลิปบาร์
แครอทอยู่ไหนครับ
เตรียมคิดว่าแครอทอยู่
สีม่วงสีม่วง 50 ม่วงด้านบนหรือสีม่วง
ด้านล่างครับ
สีม่วง
[เพลง]
ด้านล่างอยู่ด้านล่างอาทิเปิดสีม่วงด้าน
ล่างนะครับเปิดแล้วเออๆ
กูก็ต้องครับถูกต้องกระต่ายชอบกินแครอท
อ่าโอเคต้องไปให้เตรียมเปิดอีก 2 กล่อง
ครับเอาสีอะไรดีครับ
เอาสีเหลืองสีเหลืองด้านบนหรือสีเหลือง
ด้านล่างครับด้านล่างค่ะด้านล่างโอเค
เพียงติ๊ดเปิดสีเหลืองด้านล่างนะครับเปิด
หน้านี้เป็นนมเป็นนมนะครับโอเคแล้วหน้า
เปิดอีก 1 รูปครับ
อีกหนึ่งแรงด้านบน 5 ด้านบนค่าน้องเรียม
จำได้ใช่มั้ยจำได้สีแดงด้านบนมีมีอะไรมี
แมวอะไรพี่ชอบกินนมอ่านี่แมวแมวชอบกินนม
หน้านี่เพื่อที่เปิดสีแดงด้านบนห้างเปิด
แล้วปุ๊ป 5 แม่แมวถูกต้องนะครับโอเคอ่ะ
ให้น้องเรียมเลือกอีก 2 ภาพครับ 2 กล่อง
สีฟ้าอีกด้านล่างด้านล่างอ่ะสีฟ้าด้าน
ล่างตรงนี้อ่าพี่ติ๊กเปิดสีฟ้าด้านล่างนะ
ครับ
อ้าเป็นอะไรครับย่าใช่ไหมครับผมโอเคตัว
อะไรชอบกินยากครับแกะแกะโอเคน้องเรียมคิด
ว่าแกะอยู่ตรงไหนครับคิดว่าแกะอยู่สีแดง
สีแดงโอเคสีแดงอยู่ตรงนี้เพียงติ๊กเปิดสี
แดงเปิด
อออใหม่ไทยแก่มีแต่นะครับฮ่าๆอาทิตย์ปิด
ก่อนนักเรียนหาไม่เจอโอเคแค่ให้นักเรียน
เปิดอีก 2  2 กล่องครับ
ที่
สีเหลืองสีเหลืองโอเคมีสีเหลืองขวาหรือสี
เหลืองสายครับที่เสื่องซ้าย
เหลือบซ้ายอันนี้พี่ติ๊บเปิดสีเหลืองๆ
ตัวอะไร
ลิงลิงๆลิงชอบกินอะไรครับชอบกินกล้วยเย้
อ่านักเรียนคิดว่ากล้วยอยู่ตรงไหนครับ
กล้วยอยู่สีเหลือง
กลัวอยู่สีเหลือง
พรุ่งนี้ที่ไหมอ่ะเพื่อนพี่เปิดสีเหลือง
โอเค
ๆๆจะเหตุครับโอเคต่อไปต่อไปเปิดและอีก 2
รูปครับ 2 กล่องสีฟ้า
ฟ้าเลียมเลือกสีฟ้ากับสีฟ้าด้านบนหรือ
ด้านล่างครับด้านบนค่ะงานบนสีฟ้าอันนี้
อาจเพียงติ๊ดเปิดสีฟ้าด้านบนอ่ะอ่าเป็น
แก่ 5 ตอนนี้ตอนนี้น้องเรียนรู้และผู้และ
แกะท่อท่อกินอะไรนะฮ่าๆๆเพราะกินหญ้าด้วย
นะใช่อยู่ไหนครับหญ้าอยู่สีฟ้า
5 อยู่สีฟ้าโอเคสีฟ้าด้านล่างนะอยู่ตรง
นี้เพื่อติดเปิดสีฟ้าด้านล่างเปิดแล้วอ่ะ
อ่าใช่ๆอยู่ตรงนี้โอเคหน้าต่อไป 2 อันสุด
ท้ายนะครับก็หน้าเปิดสีอะไรก่อนครับกี่
ม่วงข้างบนด้านบดครับอ่าเพียงติ๊ดเปิดสี
ม่วง
มีแผนกวิ่ง
ส่วนด้านล่างอันนี้ก็เป็นเพนกวินชอบกิน
อะไรครับ
แพนกวินชอบกินปลาขอแค่พี่เปิดมาอ้าเป็น
ปลาถูกต้องครับเพนกวินชอบกินปลาโอเคอ้า
วันนี้นักเรียนทุกคนก็ได้รู้แล้วว่าสัตว์
ตัวไหนชอบกินอะไรนะครับแล้วเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้ากลับมานักเรียนภาษาไทยกับเพียร์
ตีกับน้องเรียมในช่องคอมเปียนสโตร์ไทยกัน
ใหม่คราวหน้านะครับวันนี้อ่ะหมดเวลาแล้ว
หมดเพื่อนานแล้วค่ะต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะ
ครับแค่ก็ดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ครับน้องเรียมหลายใบนัก
เรียนเย้น